Peter Brown thank you for coming in we
are gonna chat about Star Wars
Battlefront 2 and the loot crate system
as well as the progression system and
how it all works because you know what
dude it's pretty freakin confusing I so
as someone from the outside looking in
who has not had a chance to play the
beta I have not participated in the
early access I'm I'm blind yeah I you
know trying to read the sort of text
that was sent around yesterday I was
lost and even after some clarification
I'm still lost yeah and it sounds like
even though you went to a two-day review
event and you've been playing the early
access stuff there's still a little bit
of confusion or maybe you've got it I
don't know but tell you what you
understand because I I need to know yeah
and that's kind of why I have you in
here because you are a fresh perspective
so I can kind of teach you and I think I
have this unlock it's taken about three
days to review footage and to understand
all these systems in play and they have
changed since beta but my opinion is is
still the same that it is a very is a
very heavy-handed lootcrate system that
will affect your play no doubt okay we
should start with the basics I think the
basics so the how many different types
of currency are there sure you have your
credits credits and how do you earn
credits credits you get from matches and
you can also get from challenges so even
completing short levels in the campaign
you're getting 500 credits and so forth
credits are how you open crates okay so
you spend credits to open crates but not
to buy crates well oh let's move on to
the next which is crystals crystals you
can purchase and we did this on a stream
for the sake of just understanding what
warrants 100 dollars I would never buy
$100 crate I would never do that but we
did and it was it felt wrong but we
wanted to do it for the sake of just
understanding like how will this impact
your play so obviously you see here i if
i have orange and at origin access i can
get that for $10 cheaper now we did the
math yesterday and eric green and the
chat a GameSpot fan god bless him he
recorded all of our livestream so
what we got out of this was 74 crates
okay and and so how do the crystals come
into this the crystals come into it
where you you can use them for you know
buying these crates so 200 crystals for
a trooper crate which is the most
expensive right
and the microtransaction gets you
crystals and then those crystals you
convert into crates right as as another
way of opening these things up
so yeah 74 crates we opened up the
average cards per crate were roughly
four point four so four to five average
number of parts which I'll get into a
second Crafton parson was about 51 the
max being like 60 so 51 per crate per
crate is roughly what we were getting
and then as far as the cards go which we
could probably just talk about right now
the there are four different types or
tiers to cards so cards I have a weird
understanding of cards are both the
characters that you have and the
upgrades that you can apply to them
right there they're class specific so
you have yeah you have a twenty menus so
you have four classes these are the rest
here down are used to with battle points
in game so if I do well I am getting
bail points and the highest being you
know like a Luke Skywalker per se and
he's locked and I'll get into that later
and then I can use him and go ham so
yeah the cards are specific so I got
this improved thermal detonator that's
an epic and now it's worth it's worth
saying that the only from our opening of
seventy four crates the only cards we
were getting as far as the tiers which
is uncommon common rare and epic we were
only getting the up to rare I've heard
that you don't get epic cards from
crates period correct but if you
pre-ordered the game which is what I did
as well you were able to get some epic
cards so for instance there's like a
kylo Ren crate I opened up if you look
at my character and again I have I have
only played roughly three hours okay but
I didn't play kylo Ren and this is where
I'm at right now
I stars
maxing out so I'm very close to maxing
this hero out right and so is that the
same character that everyone who
pre-ordered
yes gets an Ray as well I believe and
like her Falcon or yeah and like his tie
silencer I got cards for ya if you
pre-ordered that's how those are the
characters right so again and the of the
crates of the 74 we opened rare was
getting a rare card was about 17% and an
uncommon about 52 total uncommons 74
credits yeah and then yeah total on
Commons was about 39 cards now how
crafting parts work again like with with
the normal crates you cannot get the
epic but so you'll have to craft your
way to them so again these are all the
cards that like I pretty much unlocked
through crates with the 74 that I
purchased so I'm doing pretty good right
like if you're looking at all these
characters I am looking pretty I have
cards for pretty much I have all pretty
much almost every card I'm just seeing a
lot of cards I'm having a hard time
parsing them but and I can craft cards
as well with crafting parts so is it
safe to say that and this might just be
me talking here being an outsider if
there's a hell of a lot to sort of wrap
your head around yeah managing all this
inventory and yeah absolutely and stuff
do you feel like you've got a you came
to grips with it fast enough that that's
just like a a problem just at the
beginning or does it continue to sort of
baffle it continues to baffle me it
confuse baffle me because I have a hard
time understanding like where I stand as
far as if I were not to purchase these
crates
I really cannot tell you like what
amount of time I can tell you that it's
a lot of time I can tell you that it's a
lot of time I would have to invest in
order to get these naturally in games
because of all these systems in place so
you're dealing with there's just so much
to talk about there so let me give you
some scenarios of what will we what
happened to us so here's Darth Vader let
me preview him because I am unable to
access him because he costs 60 currently
sixty thousand credits so and how many
have you been spending credits at all I
have not really spent many credits but
so it that's about seven hours or so
right less you'd get him
depending on how well you're playing
correct and more or less if you look up
here this is what I the credits in the
crafting parts these are all from what I
got in the in the crate so that I opened
the 74 for the most mostly yeah you got
credits from the crates as well oh yeah
because you are getting home so
duplicates which you get are converted
into credits as well understood so here
is a frustrating example of Darth Vader
say you're opening crates and you get
just any of these yeah but you can't use
began can't access like because you
cannot play him yet I mean how much of
this is your desire to be Darth Vader
versus you know assessing the game as it
were because I don't want to and I don't
think you're doing this but I just wanna
make sure that we're not just to play
devil's advocate here like does it seem
to be often enough that it's a cross
like the entire range of characters and
ships and things you can upgrade that
yeah for the most okay and there yeah
and there are the things you can get so
like I would say like you know you can
get weapons so for instance what should
be a milestone which are rewards for
completing 500 salt kills I can access
this weapon but I ended up getting it
through a loot crate and this attachment
these I I guess I have to do more
milestones and these all give you
advantages in battle right like that
absolutely different weapons that are
higher powered let's say or at least
cards obviously yeah look at these
health regeneration delays shorter than
normal short but you can put up to 40%
which is very significant it is very
significant so now here's the the other
part of this that I think is I find like
a slight cushion to pushing back the
idea of being at pay2win is that I have
my class specific ranks but I also have
my overall rank which is for okay
so ideally you want the best cards on
all these things correct so that's this
right here now I get a card I can
obviously I can craft it but then I then
I use crafting parts to upgrade it
what's holding me back is my overall
rank currently 415 is when I can upgrade
this to a rare and then I believe it's
480 parts that's very interesting to get
it to 40 so you have to perform well to
get the things you need to do the thing
but then you also need to be higher
level to actually see that through
correct it's basically a form of gating
to prevent yeah to prevent me as I had
spent real-world money for crates to
spend some money dude you'll be fine
right but my point but my overall point
is that it's it's a gate - I think
cushioned this idea
so again when I when I hit say I think
it's like maybe ranked overall ranked 25
I'm rocking I'm rocking dude I have 3000
almost 4,000 crafting parts I'm you're
damn right I have having spending my
credit set I can keep going and get it
and get many more crafting parts so when
I hit and if I play you know just enough
so say maybe if I play it hard enough
maybe in a week generously I I can craft
my way to have the best cards and all
them and the other thing that's worth
noticing or noting is that is it's a
little weird that I'm 22 well that's
because I have really good cards your
class rank your class rank is determined
by the amount and the quality of the
cards you possess so when you start the
game fresh you have one card slot when
you get to phyla rank five class
specific you get another card slot when
you get to ten you get that third one so
on face value by spending all that money
and getting all these cards I was
immediately able to get that third card
slot and immediately fill all of of my
classes so so when you rank up right you
said like at five you get your second
card slot at ten your third right and
one of the ways that you rank up is by
the quality of the cards that you own
correct so if you quality an amount I
believe right so if you let's say buy
crates to get more cards and you get a
lot of rare ones that will then increase
your rank and allow you to use them
right versus playing to get to that
point playing to open crate right and
get more or to use crafting parts and
get more cards yeah okay I obviously
need to play this game more to
experience you know the ebb and flow of
earning and spending and you know
unlocking things but yeah man I it's a
it's a bit frustrating because this is
actually like a bit off-putting I
no if I want to play multiplayer if
these are the things I have to contend
with it seems tough to get in the way of
the game yeah you don't I mean yeah but
I mean I will have to see how that
diminishing returns thing you know if
that happens how that feels if the
gameplay can still make this worth
playing I guess we're early it's it's
the are using yeah and and this is just
yeah again this is like I mean early or
the EA origin access trial so I'm able
to play 10 hours of the game before the
game comes out so yeah I mean I guess
that's kind of it in a nutshell all
right well we've got obviously a lot
more Star Wars Battlefront to to play
the campaign we've only really got a
taste for and multiplayer seems like you
know we really have to see how that pans
out yeah so we will have our review
sometime next week in the meantime hop
on to EA Origin access if you want to
get a taste of the game for yourself Rob
thanks for explaining the stuff to me
thank you for coming in taking a look
[Music]